there's a theory in most contests the
team having more fun wins and the team
that loses its sense of humor loses
period take Friday when President Trump
posted a mean predicting he'll be
President forever and ever
[Music]
yeah that's real normal people ie people
not in the media and therefore not under
the spell of irrational obsessions saw
this as light-hearted trolling mocking
the triggered Trump critics like this
fella here if he loses Trump he won't go
I've been saying that since before he
got elected and he was a comedian once
it's so obvious it hurts but still the
media reports Trump's jokes as dire
warnings immediate headlines screams
Trump posts insane Twitter video
threatening to be president for eternity
threatening what [ __ ] writes this stuff
it's hard to say really they got a staff
of them I'm anxiously awaiting their
expose and why the chicken really
crossed the road or does time fly if you
throw a clock through the air I bet that
gets three Pinocchio's how do these
people get so to use the medical term
stupid well the media once operating
under the guise of journalism are now
just hall monitors and pundants their
jobs reduced to screaming look what some
would said on TV it's a joke but not to
us they barely get out of bed anymore
the workplace attire sweatpants and an
open bathrobe but that's today's media
reporting on you as you make them the
butt of the joke like Chuck you um
you've joked about a third term you've
joked about the only joke okay I joke
and I say watch I will drive me crazy
okay you will yes the result never
happens in 2020 yes
you'll be like you're not gonna like it
but you walk out in fact I said it a
speech recently I said watch will drive
the media crazy let's go for a third
term and then a fourth and some of the
media said he is going to do it what a
treat the trolled reporting on how they
got trolled it's too easy and almost
unfair to think we're gonna have at
least two three or four terms of this
DNA do they do how do they did he
deliberately see jokes as the real thing
or is this it really is a disorder it's
becoming one guy obviously that was
funny
yes also he's 73 yeah
that's not obviously not happening they
they obviously you can't have more than
two terms it takes a constitutional
amendment they can't even joke about
that but if you talk about abolishing
the electoral college yes like that is
that's actually real that's not a joke
that is a good point a good point Jesse
yeah I just like watching the Democrats
chase their own tail it's so stupid
they're humorless this is like like what
you said in the beginning if Trump
suites something that he's never gonna
leave then Maura says he's not going to
leave then he asked him about leaving he
says I'm just joking and then they run
stories of how the president might not
be joking he could be serious when in
fact it's Hillary and the left who
hasn't accepted the last results of the
election remember they called him an
illegitimate Russian hacker for two
years and then you have all the
holdovers like Yates and McCabe and
Comey trying to constantly undermine
them from within but I think the
strategy for the media Greg is that
they're trying to give the Democrat
voters a shot of adrenaline and say you
guys need to be trumped by a larger
margin it can't be a small margin it
can't be like a million votes you have
to beat them handily in the electoral
college because this guy's a felon
this guy's a cheater this guy's a
willing polluter and if it's if it's
really close he's going to say there's
fraud he's going to say you guys cheated
and he's going to stay in office so I
think that's the strategy
what's the amendment again that's the
limits your terms I can't right now
he talks about article two all the time
an article two establishes the executive
branch and says that it's two terms yeah
so I think he should these next things
should say we should repeal that repeal
yes repeal it well you know the thing
about this is on the one hand at the end
of the 2016 race when people asked him
what happens if you said well maybe
maybe not I'll accept the results right
and I don't know if he was joking there
but that's what he said no he won then
he says to Chuck Todd in the same
interview he says oh you know I won the
popular vote in Chuck Todd says what are
you talking about he says oh well
Judicial Watch had this suit in
California of course that suit was about
people who were should have been taken
off the registrations there was no
evidence of
fraudulent voting taking place so to me
the question is why are we having this
segment proved Greg's point they cannot
have fun and you take this so directly
but he says things Lisa that make and
not crack up I love the fact that he's
doing more of these mainstream
interviews because I think it's
absolutely hilarious the scene with him
and Stephanopoulos in the car talking
about if there's collusion or not made
me laugh out loud this is hilarious and
people make it so easy and easier they
make it the more he's going to want to
do it and so you actually benefit
yourself by not overreacting to it
because then he'd probably be less
inclined to want to do it but it's not
just Hillary Clinton that can't accept
the results of the election for 2016 you
have Stacey Abrams who is still saying
that she is governor of Georgia she lost
by fifty five thousand votes in 2018 and
you have people like Joe Biden and Pete
buta jej all these Democrats that know
better that are saying that somehow she
would have been the governor of Georgia
despite the fact that the 2018 midterm
elections in Georgia so near
presidential levels and turnout so
clearly nobody was suppressed there is a
tremendous amount of people that turned
out she just lost they didn't vote for
her well I think that you should keep in
mind that Brian Kemp who's now the
governor was the one was the Attorney
General and was acting in Sochi one he's
got he's the one who's not was in fact
not governor's in polling places the
governor but anyway my point to you Lisa
is the president is a powerful man we
should not be sitting here having to
debate
that is joking cuz we know he's Joe no I
don't look under sound joking it's what
he's outgoing Florida what maybe it
could be a baby but your neighbor Gore
was really president just like Stacy
should be asking the Democrats will you
accept the results of the 2012 election
she said I consider him a legitimate
governor I think so I think Al Gore
conceded I think conceded Al Gore and
Stacey Abrams had a different no I just
think that I think Stacy every color
except will stand and say you can marry
your sibling but don't make jokes